[Applause]
hi I'm Paula powers are you struggling
with the endless tedium of everyday
modern life do you miss the unstoppable
feeling of the 1980s I know I do and
this program is designed to pump you up
and give you a dose of excitement with
these fun and easy steps
[Music]
now first thing we're gonna do to warm
up it get through the morning meeting by
doing a comparison of sales versus
profit let's start with three reps of
looking alive sit up and drink Jimmy
that was the responsibility of your
department wasn't it and nod a five six
seven eight all right it's email time
we're doing this together and tight and
tight up that's passive aggressive undo
undo look for the perfect gift instead
is it gif or Jif modern dating can be a
struggle but you are worth it and you
can do it you're worthy of love come on
now
swipe left swipe left you don't need
that guy in your life his profile says
he's a DJ but I like DJs no don't do it
come on don't be afraid to make the
first move
oh yes what riot it's like right you're
on fire olives there let's make that
love connection happen let's get real
ask her about her interest don't forget
to lift it and hobbies I love to break
down oh my gosh me too me are you
breathing beginners no need to do this
on your first try make a joke and they
called it the World Wide Web and that's
it great workout
now wasn't that easy and fun now
remember to rewind your tape so you can
try again tomorrow